اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
معنا فيها دائما المحلل العسكري اللواء
فايز الدويري اهلا بك قبل ان نتحدث للواء
فايز الدويري نذهب لابرز التطورات على
الخريطه التفاعليه ميدانيا معك سلام خضر
شكرا عبد السلام اذا تطورات ميدانيه
متسارعه جدا في قطاع غزه من اقصى الشمال
الى اقصى نقطه في الجنوب اليوم الاشتباكات
التي على اكثر من محور توحي وكان الحرب
الاسرائيليه على القطاع لا تزال في
بدايتها لكن سنبدا من النقطه الاهم اليوم
اعلنت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بصدد التوغل في من اقصى الشمال
من اقصى شرق قطاع غزه الى
الداخل قالت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي دفع بمدرعات عبر معبر
كرم ابو سالم وهو معبر تجاري يصل قطاع غزه
بالاراضي الاسرائيليه وقالت هذه وسائل
الاعلام ان الهدف من ذلك ان يتوغل جيش
الاحتلال من نقطه معبر كرم ابو سالم وصولا
الى البحر المتوسط تقريبا بعرض 14 م بهدف
واضح كما يقول الاعلام الاسرائيلي انشاء
منطقه زله الى بين القطاع وبين تمركز
القوات الاسرائيليه طبعا هذا لم ياتي هذا
الخبر لم ياتي خارج السياق امس كنا نتحدث
ايضا عن ان الاسرائيليين بداوا يقولون ان
الحرب ستنتقل الى المرحله الثالثه وسنعود
الى هذه النقطه ولكن قبل ان ننتقل من
المنطقه الجنوبيه خان يونس اليوم تشهد
اشتباكات ضاريه جدا واشتباكات مباشره جدا
كتائب القسام قالت بدايه انها استهدفت
الاليات المتوغلة
من الخسائر في صفوف الجنوب الجنود
الاسرائيليين هذه التطورات المتلاحقه ايضا
رافقها تطورات لا تقل اهميه عما يجري
جنوبا ولكن هذه المره في المنطقه القريبه
من المحافظات الوسطى مدينه غزه جنوب مدينه
غزه لا تزال بؤره اشتباكات قويه واليوم
هناك اكثر من عمليه نفذها القسام وكتائب
شهداء وسرايا القدس ايضا وقالوا انهم
اوقعوا اصابات الاهم من ذلك هو ما جرى في
جحر الديك منطقه جحر الديك هي واحده من
اوائل المناطق التي توغل اليها الجيش
الاسرائيلي عند بدء هذه الحرب اليوم منطقه
جحر الديك تشهد اشتباكات واستهداف من قبل
الفصائل المقاومه عز الدين القسام هاجمت
هذا الموقع وايضا اوقعت خسائر في صفوف
الاسرائيليين ه بالتوازي مع هذه الامور
كانت ايضا الجبهه الشماليه اقصى
شمال قطاع غزه يشهد تطورات مفاجئه الجيش
الاسرائيلي كان اعلن انه سيطر على منطقه
بيت حنون بيت لاهيا جباليا اليوم في
جباليا هناك
اشتباكات في جباليا هناك اشتباكات وايضا
في بيت حنون هناك عبوه وضعت للجيش
الاسرائيلي نشير الى مساله اخيره فقط الى
ان الاهالي او الصليب الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني تمكن من الوصول الى بيت لاهيه
في اقصى شمال القطاع واكتشف فضائع ارتكبها
جيش الاحتلال بالمدنيين يقول الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني انه عثر على رفاه شهداء
قتلوا اعداما من مسافات قريبه عبد السلام
باختصار هذه ابرز المجريات اليوم في قطاع
غزه اعتقد انك ربما ستتحدث عن المنطقه
العازله ما هي بطبيعه الحال بطريقه اوسع
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه الايضاحات نذهب
بهذا الحديث من سلام خضر للواء فايز
الدويري ربما الحديث عن استهدافات متواصله
في بعض المناطق الشماليه ما زالت مستمره
انت تحدثت دائما عن ان هذه المناطق
السيطره عليها عندما يقال عملياتي ليس في
واقع الامر كذلك باعتبار ان هذه العمليات
لا لا تزال مستمره جحر الديك بيت لاهيه
بيت حانون وجباليا لازالت الاشتباكات
مستمره نعم يعني دعني القي نظره عامه
وتوصيف عام في عجاله اولا منذ ان صدرت
الاوامر بسحب الكتيبه 13 من لواء جولاني
مساء اول امس كان لها مؤشر واضح وهي ان
جيش الاحتلال وصل الى نقطه التحول ما هي
نقطه التحول عندما تفقد القوات المهاجمه
القدره على ادامه الهجوم تلج او الى اما
التموضع او الى التراجع في السياق
الاستراتيجي واعني هنا على مستوى قياده
جيش الاحتلال وصلت الى نقطه التحول وهذا
ما ما يؤكده الواقع و اشارت بعض المصادر
بتصريحات لوزير دفاع جيش الاحتلال يطالب
نتنياهو باعاده تقيييم الوضع واعاده النظر
بالاهداف الموضوعه حاليا والتي لا يستطيع
ان يحققها ننتقل الى المستوى الادنى وهو
المستوى
العملياتي المستوى العمليات في القاطع
الشمالي وصل الى نقطه التحول وما
الانسحابات التي تجري في شمال جباليا وفي
بقيه المناطق الا مؤشر واضح على ذلك ابقى
في المنطقه الشماليه كذلك في المستوى
التكتيكي بعض الوحدات ليس جميعها بدات
تتراجع الان نذهب الى المنطقه الجنوبيه في
نفس الاطار والسياق لا لا يزال
يمتلك المباداه ولم يصل الى نقطه التحول
في المستوى العملياتي وما يؤكد ذلك ما
يجري من معارك في منطقه خزاعه بني سهيله
شرق خان يونس
وتحديدا معبر او
اي فيلادلفيا محور فيلادلفيا الذي يحاول
ان يعبر من معبر كرم ابو سالم الى رفح
وصولا الى شارع الرشيد هذا هو الصوره
العامه لكن اذا ذهبنا بصوره تفصيليه نجد
ان هذا اليوم رغم انه اليوم
ال8 يعتبر من الايام التي ستسجل في
تاريخ بسبب كم الضربات المؤلمه وابدا ببعض
النقاط اذا ذهبنا شمالا تم تفجير صاروخين
زنت كل واحد واحد طن وهي لم تنفجر تم
اعاده تجهيزها وهذه في المجال الهندسي امر
سهل جدا باستخدام حشوات
معينه يتم
تفجيرها عن بعد تم تجهيز الصاروخين وعندما
دخلت قوات جيش الاحتلال الى منطقه التاثير
تم تفجيرها وتدمير خمسه دبابات هذه نقطه
في منطقه جحر الديك ماذا حدث طبعا هناك
احداث اخرى حدثت في جباليا لكن
من اجل المحافظه على الوقت في جحر الديك
حدثت اكثر من عمليه نوعيه اربع سيارات جيب
باطقم وقعت في حقل الغام مختلط اي بمعنى
ضد به حشوات ضد الافراد وحشوات ضد الاليات
وتم القضاء عليها تم استدراج ه هل هل تقدر
الجيب كم يحمل عاده تختلف لا نستطيع ان
نجزم لكن لن يكون فيه اقل من اربعه الى
خمسه افراد هذا في الحد الادنى حتى لا لا
يكون في التقديرات اربع جيبات تم
استهدافها بشكل مباشر
وصبات قيل وج واضح تم القضاء على من فيها
استدراج مجموعه الى فتحه النفق وتم
تفجيره عمليه قنص لاربعه من مسافه الصفر
ام اذا هذه محاكاه لما حدث من من تفجيرات
وتم توفي نعم الان هذه يعني الان عندما
نتحدث عن منطقه يتم تجهيزها وتلغيم
بحشوات ضد الدبابات وضد الافراد هذه لها
ميكانيزم معين واعتقد الهندسه في القسام
وغيرها لها درايه كامله هذه عمليه
الاستدراج الى النفق وبالتالي القضاء
عليهم الان العمليات في منطقه خانيونس هي
عمليات كذلك عمليات محتدمه قويه هناك
ايقاع خسائر لكن لم ترد
تفصيلات محدده ساعود عن الخسائر نتوقع
انها ستصل نعم لكن عند هذه النقطه فقط نقف
مع هذه المحاكاه لما حدث ما تاثير مثل هذه
العمليات عندما يتم تفجير الافراد
باستخدام هذا هذه الطريقه في النفق ايضا
اعاده استخدام بعض الصواريخ التي لم تنفجر
بهذا الشكل هل هل انعكاسه على جيش
الاحتلال ان يكون اكثر حذرا يؤخر عملياته
على الارض هو اذا كان حذرا اذا كان حذرا
لا لا يقع في ذلك يعني هذا الفيديو فتحه
النفق يمكن يكون يكون الثامن اذا لم اكن
مخطئا السابع او الثامن يتم الاستدراج الى
فتحه النفق وتكون ملغمه هذه صوره تعبيريه
جيده ام هذه صوره تعبيريه اكثر وضوحا
وبالتالي هذه تعبر عن ما ماذا يجري في
الميدان واما استخدام الصواريخ واعاده
تجهيزها وتفجيرها تدل على ابداع شخصي
والمحاوله الاستفاده من كل شيء يمكن توظيف
الان كانهم قالوا للخمس دبابات وهي تعادل
سريه ناقص فصلين فاصلين ناقص كانهم يقول
لهم هذه بضاعتكم ردت اليكم عن هذه النقطه
ردت اليكم هل تاثيرها يكون اقوى من تاثير
الاسلحه التي ت تملكها بطبيعه الحال الفصا
من المؤكد الان هذ الخمس دبابات كان يمكن
استهداف دبابه واحده باندم او في الياسين
او اكثر من دبابه لكن
ان يكون
من وضع من جهز هذه الصواريخ موجود في في
نقطه محدده هناك مجال رؤيه يجب ان يكون
مجال رؤيه ويكون لديه من الصبر والتاني
والاناء حتى تكون الخمس دبابات ضمن مدى
التفجير القاتل ويقوم بالتفجير هذه هي روع
او قمه الاداء المميز والروعه في هذا لكن
هذه لكن هل هي لم تكن مجهزه لاستخدام ضد
الدبابات ام ان لها تاثير كبير نعم الان
اتحدث اتحدث عن صاروخ وزنه 1
طن 2000 باوند هذا يوجد به تقريبا
45% من الوزن الاجمالي متفجرات اي تقريبا
بحدود 430 غرام من المتفجرات عندما تفجر
430 غرام وتفجيرها يكون تاثيره مضاعف اذا
فجرتها في العراء في الهواء
لها تاثير محدد لكن هذه اين موجوده موجوده
في الصاروخ الصاروخ غلافه فولاذي سمك
الغلاف واحد بوصه 2 وص سنتيمتر هذا يتفجر
ويتحول الى شضايا وبالتالي اذا كان هناك
افراد يتم القضاء عليهم اذا كانت اليات
عاديه يتم القضاء عليها من الشظايا واذا
كانت دبابات الان تدخل العمليه المزدوجه
لانه اختار لحظه التفجير عندما كانت
الدبابات قريبه جدا من الصاروخ فعمل العصف
والشظايا تؤدي الى تدمير وتعطيل هذه
الاليات قد لا يكون تدميرا مطلقا لكن قد
يكون احداث ضرر بليغ يفضي الى تعطيل
الاليه بصوره كامله وقتل كل من فيها على
قضيه هذا هذا هذه المحاكاه للانفاق الجانب
الاسرائيلي تحدث عن انه اكتشف نفق يضم
مركز قياده والى ما هنالك وعرض صور ل كلب
بوليسي يحمل كاميرا دخل الى النفق هذه
الخطوه استكشاف الانفاق قبل الدخول اليها
باستخدام الكلاب البوليسيه هل تحمي جيش
الاحتلال من الاستهداف المباشر في حين انه
اليوم يتم الحديث عن استهداف اخر في و كان
هناك فيلم سابق عندما تم
ايقاع مجموعه من قوات النخبه تم القضاء
عليهم وتم قتل الكلب وكان الكلب يحمل يحمل
كاميرا كذلك هذه نعم هذه احد وسائل كشف
الالغام يتم التضحيه بالحيوان لانه يعني
يتحمل ظروف معينه قد لا يتحملها الانسان
ويبقى الحفاظ على حياه الجندي نعم قد يفضي
لكن ثبت من التجارب السابقه ان القدره لدى
الكلاب على الدخول في الانفاق لا تتجاوز
400 يارد او متر ام في هذا اليوم عندما
تحدثوا عن النفق الذي انت ذكرته قالوا
طوله 400 يارد اذا هذا الكلب وصل الى ال
النقطه القصوى في الوصول ويتحدث عن نفق من
400 متر مقابل انفاق تبلغ 500 م امم اذا
هذه المعلومات التي تتحدث عنها يتحدث عنها
الجانب الاسرائيلي بانه يحاول التخفيف من
اثار الدخول الى الانفاق لكن اعيد هذه
النقطه بانه مع ذلك ما زال هناك استهداف
بهذه بهذا التكنيك وبهذه الطريقه والسؤال
هل يمكن لفصائل المقاومه الالتفاف حول هذه
الطريقه استخدام الكلاب البوليسيه
والتاثير في الباحثين عن الافاق الان هذه
يعتمد على ميكانيكيات اداره المعركه داخل
الانفاق وهذا يعتمد يختلف من نفق الى نفق
حسب مواصفات النفق نفسه
امكانيه
توظيف طبيعه النفق لعمليات الرصد
والاستهداف
ومدى ارتباطه بالانفاق الاخرى اذا هنا لا
نستطيع اسقاط ق هذا الكلام على كافه
الحالات لكن في حالات معينه نعم ه هون
اشاروا ان النفق طوله 400 متر وهي المسافه
التي يستطيع الكلب ان يدخلها وبعد ذلك
يصبح غير فاعل بسبب الظلام ب بسبب انقطاع
الاتصال معه الى غ الاتصال مع الاجهزه
التي يحملها حتى لا يفسر كلامي انه يتم
الاتصال مع الكلب لا هناك هو يحمل اجهزه
تستطيع تح تحديد مك تحديد مكانه والى غير
ذلك اذا هذا يعتمد على الوضع في في تلك
الجزئيه من شبكه الانفاق لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه اعود واستخدم ما استخدمته قبل 77
يوم كلمه الصندوق الاسود في في سؤال اخير
واذا عدنا الى الخريطه موضوع محور
فيلادلفيا ربما تحدثت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه من قبل بانه ضمن خطه لاحقه
يفترض في العمليه العسكريه الدخول اليها
مباشره اليوم ما دلالاته بالنسبه لك
استكمال الان الحديث بالامس تركز حول
المنطقه العازله والمنطقه العازله قراءتنا
كانت من خلال الخارطه وا وطبيعه اداره
المعركه انها ستغطي الاتجاهات الثلاث
الشماليه والشرقيه والجنوبيه
وستخطئ هي تقريبا 12 م او 11 م و 11 و700
متر وبالتالي يوجد فيها معبر كرم ابو سالم
فتحه المعبر تبعد 460 متر عن السياج
الفاصل وبالتالي تدخل اي كانت هذا
للشاحنات تدخل ال الشاحنات من فلسطين
المحتله ولا اقول الكيان الاسرائيلي الى
معبر رفح ومعبر الى معبر كرم ابو سالم
معبر رفح يبعد 3600 متر هي تسعى للوصول
الان كان الخبر العاجل ايقاع خسائر و
والانسحاب لكن هذا لا يعني انه سيتراجع عن
تلك المحاوله سيقوم بمحاولات اخرى بضخ
قوات اضافيه قد يصل الى شارع الرشيد لكن
الثمن باهظ والاكثر ايلاما له هل يستطيع
التثبت والسيطره اشك في ذلك ام لكن هو
يتحدث دائما عن الخطه العامه وهو وضع امن
جديد بالنسبه لغزه هل هذا ممكن هو ليقول
ما يقول هو كان يتحدث عن القضاء على حماس
عن تهجير اهل غزه تحدث كثيرا حتى مساء
الامس نتنياهو يتحدث عن ما بعد حماس وخلال
لحظات واذا هو يتحدث عن بدء المعركه
المرحله الثالثه اذا انا لا استند كثيرا
ولا اتوقف كثيرا عند تصريحاته شكرا جزيلا
لك اللواء فايز الدوير الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي على كل ما تفضلت به